in a worldwide study 58 of students did
not solve this problem we have a
triangle with sides of A and B that are
opposite angles of 45 degrees and 60
degrees what is the value of a squared
over B squared one way to solve this
problem is to use the Law of Sines a
over the sine of angle a is equal to B
over the sine of angle B we solve this
equation for the ratio A over B we
substitute in for the angles A and B and
evaluate the signs of these angles and
then we simplify to get that A over B is
equal to root 2 over root 3. we score
both sides to get the a squared over B
squared is equal to two over three
now there's another way you can solve
this problem using geometry construct an
altitude with length x then we have a 30
60 90 right triangle so a is equal to X
multiplied by 2 over root 3. here we
have another special right triangle so B
is equal to X root 2. we then substitute
in for A over B and we simplify to get
that A over B is equal to root 2 over 3
so once again a squared over B squared
is equal to two over three